When you're at home, even when you're on an interview,...
...you kind of have that more casual atmosphere...
...than actually going into an office building to interview,...
...and with that casual feeling,...
...you might end up doing something...
...that you wouldn't even think of in an office setting.
For example, having your phone out.
So, just turn it off and put it out of sight...
...and make sure you have all of your internet browsers and windows closed.
You don't need that open.
Really, the only thing you should have open...
...on your computer during the interview...
...is the program that you're using to conduct the interview.
Remote interviews and video interviews are a lot different.
They really are, but as they become more mainstream,...
...it's important that we adapt and adjust to them.
That way, we can still continue on with our careers...
...and making career moves...
...and not letting the fear of video interviews hold us back.